Professor John Rogers:
I'm actually going to
continue here one of the
discussions that I had begun in
the last lecture,
which involved the matter of
the relationship of this poem,
Paradise Regained,
to the earlier epic,
which we have to acknowledge is
in so many ways the more
ambitious poem,
Paradise Lost.
I want to look at the way in
which Milton uses this new poem,
Paradise Regained,
to explore the larger
problem of identity and in a lot
of ways, the identity of Milton
himself: Milton's identity as an
obedient son of God,
Milton's identity as a poet.
All of this gets worked out
over the course of the poem.
Each of the characters in
Paradise Regained,
Satan and the Son -- each
of them is involved in an
elaborate process,
and it's really a process that
spans the entire poem,
of trying to figure out who the
other one is.
On top of that,
each of them is trying to
figure out who he himself is --
or who he himself has been,
in the Son's case.
I don't know what page this is
on, but it's in Book One,
lines 355 and 356.
This is the Son speaking to
Satan, and I think it's an
extraordinary thing for the Son
to say.
The Son says to Satan:
"Why dost thou then suggest to
me distrust, / knowing who I am,
as I know who thou art?"
Of course, we are -- how can we
not be?
-- inclined to assume,
because this is the Son of God
after all, that there's
something more meaningful about
this statement than actually is
the case.
What does the Son know?
The Son does know that Satan is
his enemy and that Satan is to
be identified with that serpent
from the Protoevangelium,
the prophecy back in
Genesis whom it will be the
Son's job to destroy.
The Son knows that,
and Satan knows that the Son is
his enemy and that it will be
the Son's job as the Messiah to
destroy him.But this is
still just a partial knowledge,
and it's remarkable,
the extent to which Milton
doesn't let on just how partial
this knowledge is.
We don't know until the end how
little the Son and Satan
actually understand about
themselves and about each other.
And so I think the Son is
actually wrong in some way at
this early point in the poem to
claim that he knows who Satan
is,
because his is,
of course, just a partial
knowledge.
Satan doesn't know fully who
the Son is, and the Son doesn't
know fully who Satan is.
Each of them on some level
knows who the other is,
but neither of them knows who
the other has been -- I'm
hoping that will make more sense
by the time we get to the end of
our period here.Okay.
So what little action,
what little drama this poem
affords us -- and we have to
confess it is relatively little
-- involves just this struggle,
this intellectual struggle to
understand one's identity.
I think that the search for
identity represented in the poem
in a lot of ways is a reflection
of,
or something like a narrative
version of, Milton's own
attempts -- and we've been
tracking this for a long time
now -- Milton's own attempts to
identify himself.
So one of the questions I think
at stake here is who is John
Milton?
Who is this man?
Who is this man who dared to
rewrite scripture in his
twelve-book epic poem
Paradise Lost?I think
this poem is everywhere trying
to answer that question,
and it begins answering it at
the very opening.
Look at the beginning of
Paradise Regained.
This is page 483 of the
Hughes.
I [and obviously,
this is Milton the narrator
talking to us]
who erewhile the happy Garden
sung,
By one mans disobedience lost,
now sing
Recover'd Paradise to all
mankind,
By one mans firm obedience
fully tried…
Obviously Milton is drawing our
attention to the earlier
achievement, the epic that had
begun with that prepositional
phrase,
"of man's first disobedience."
So the poet very carefully
wrings a variation on that
phrase in the forced line of the
new poem, and the new phrase is
"by one's man firm obedience."
This little modulation
reflects, of course,
the change of subject
matter.But look at the way
in which Milton has -- this is
unbelievable to me -- look at
how he has characterized his
authorship of the earlier poem:
"I who erewhile the happy
Garden sung."
Now just pause for a moment and
think about what kind of way
that is to refer to the
magnificent epic achievement
that is Paradise Lost.
Milton's alluding -- he
hasn't made up this convention
-- he's alluding in these lines
to the opening of Virgil's epic,
The Aeneid,
and also to the beginning
of Spenser's romance epic,
The Faerie Queene;
Spenser, of course,
was himself alluding to Virgil.
Virgil and Spenser had begun
their vast and ambitious
literary project by identifying
themselves to the readers,
and so each of them in his way
began their huge poems like
this: "I, the poet,
who had sung of happy gardens,
who had been content writing
pastoral poems -- diminutive,
little pastoral lyrics -- I'm
now embarking on an epic,
and an epic,
as you all know from having
read Homer,
is a poem that treats of
heroism and of war.
I have graduated to epic
ambition."
That's how Spenser began The
Faerie Queene and that's how
Virgil before him had begun
The Aeneid.
By the time we get to the
Renaissance, this is really the
standard way of introducing your
epic poem.Okay.
That's fine.
But what sense is there to
Milton's beginning Paradise
Regained this way?
[laughs]
He should have done this before
in Paradise Lost.
What sense does it make for
Milton to begin this poem
with that conventional epic
opening?
Milton had already written his
epic.
Not only had Milton already
written his epic,
but he had written his
diminutive,
little pastoral lyrics long
before that -- I'd say maybe
thirty years before the
publication of Paradise
Regained.
"Lycidas," Comus,
"L'Allegro," and "Il
Penseroso" -- those were
Milton's pastoral poems.
Those were the poems in which
he sang the happy garden,
but to identify Paradise
Lost as a simple pastoral
about a happy garden is
obviously on some level to get
it wrong.
I think there's everything
riding on the fact that Milton
has misidentified the nature of
his Paradise Lost.
This is going to be the
working assumption of the rest
of this lecture:
that Milton on some level --
and I know this sounds
far-fetched -- but Milton has
repressed the epic content of
his epic poem.Now,
you'll remember that last time
we saw how Satan in Paradise
Regained had repressed the
fact that it was,
in fact, the Son of God who had
brought him to the brink of
destruction during the war in
heaven.
He had repressed a crucial fact
about that war,
perhaps the most crucial fact
about that war.
Well, on some level the speaker
of the poem, Milton's narrator
-- we can call him Milton --
joins Satan in this act of
repression,
and the speaker of this poem
has repressed the fact of the
war in heaven as well.
It's as if he had forgotten
that Paradise Lost was an
epic, something more than a poem
merely about a happy garden,
because an epic necessarily
features the epic subject of
war.
Paradise Lost can't be
identified merely with Book
Four, our introduction to the
Garden of Eden,
needless to say.It's not
just that Paradise Lost
featured that lush,
extraordinarily beautiful style
of poetry that Milton feels in
some way he has to resist in
Paradise Regained.
It's not just the lure of
the rich, classical style that
was so tempting there.
It's also the fact that
Paradise Lost
represented,
gave us an image of,
heroic actions,
the heroic actions of its
characters.
Its characters actually did
something, a fact that we didn't
know we were supposed to
appreciate so much when we were
actually reading the thing;
but now that we're reading
Paradise Regained,
the fact that the characters
[laughs]
actually act and do in
Paradise Lost takes on a
new meaning.
The very fact of all of that
action that had been represented
in Paradise Lost has
become something of a problem by
the time we get to Paradise
Regained.Now,
we remember that when Milton in
those early poems was
considering his problems of
career and of vocation,
he was consistently imagining a
tension between those two
parables in the Gospel of
Matthew that posed the question
of action,
the question of work.
The parable of the talents
-- this lecture in some
way will be something like a
review session for the whole
semester up to this point --
suggested that hard work and
initiative were absolutely
essential for the Father's
approval,
while the parable of the
workers in the vineyard gave us
a different understanding.
It suggested in some way that
the Father approves of the
individual who is willing merely
to wait to be called to work.
The conflicting,
or what seemed to be the
conflicting, implications of
those two parables were worked
over in dozens of earlier poems
and in prose treatises,
and they're reworked here in
Paradise Regained again,
much later in Milton's career.
They're reworked in the three
temptations that the Son of God
undergoes at the hand of Satan
in Paradise
Regained.So this for me
is one of the most amazing and
most surprising aspects of
Satan's temptation of the Son of
God in this poem.
In Paradise Lost,
Satan had tempted Eve to be
disobedient, and it was clear to
everyone that this was a kind of
temptation to evil.
But the situation in
Paradise Regained -- this
is a much more complicated poem.
It's infinitely more complex,
the nature of these
temptations.
Satan in this poem is tempting
the Son not to act disobediently
but, on some level,
actually to act virtuously or
to exhibit what strikes us as
virtuous behavior.Now,
the cardinal virtues,
you'll remember from an earlier
discussion of Comus,
are faith,
hope, and charity.
In Milton's account -- and it's
ingenious -- Satan tempts the
Son with those virtues,
but he does it in precisely the
reverse order.
He tempts the Son to an act of
charity and then to an act of
hope and then an act of faith.
Now, just think of what Milton
does to the original story in
Luke.
Okay: so the Son is hungry
after forty days of fasting in
the wilderness.
Now in the account from the
Gospel of Luke,
Satan responds to the Son's
hunger by tempting him to turn
this stone into bread.
He's tempting him to provide
himself with something to
eat.Well,
Milton goes way beyond that,
and in Paradise Regained
Satan doesn't merely tempt
the Son of God to eat something
himself.
That would be far too easy for
the Son to resist.
He asks the Son to turn the
stone into bread so he can
perform the virtuous,
the charitable,
act of feeding the hungry and
of feeding the poor.
"We are starving here," a
disguised Satan tells the Son,
and, in a magnificent line that
strikes me as perfectly
prophetic of the vegan movement
of the late twentieth century,
Satan says sublimely,
"We here / live on tough Roots
and Stubs."
This is the kind of -- I don't
know if you get those emails
that I get from a woman named
Anastasia Curley from the Yale
Sustainable Food Project,
but I think of her [laughter]
with those updates from what's
happening at the farm when I
read this line,
"We here live on tough roots
and stubs, and we're asking for
your help."
That's what Satan says,
and it's this temptation,
the temptation to virtuous
action, that the Son has to
resist.
It's not a simple temptation to
gluttony in any way as it seems
to be in the Gospel original.
Satan is tempting the Son --
what?
-- to exhibit a little
humanity, to do the right
thing.Milton's father,
John Milton,
Sr., had pressed the young
Milton to stop reading at home
and to begin doing something.
His father was pressuring
Milton to perform the virtuous
action of a clergyman,
and it was just this form of
virtuous action that Milton,
of course -- and we remember
this -- was continually
resisting.
He insisted repeatedly that he
wasn't ready yet,
he wasn't ready to start
acting.
"It's too soon," we found him
continually protesting.
"I'm not ripe yet."
He was constantly explaining to
that paternal authority that he
had in some way internalized the
fact of his unripeness.Of
course,
it seems to be something just
like the voice of Milton's
father, which is nothing other
than Milton's own conscience,
that constitutes the essence of
the next temptation.
That's the temptation to accept
the worldly kingdoms from Satan
as Satan's gift.
It's the second temptation
which really takes up the bulk
of the poem.
Milton takes this verse from
the Gospel of Luke and explodes
it into hundreds and hundreds of
lines.
It stretches from the middle of
Book Two to the middle of Book
Four, and it's here that Milton
really most powerfully distorts
his scriptural source.
He takes what you could think
of as a kind of brief,
throwaway temptation from the
Gospel of Luke,
and he expands it into a set of
several sub temptations.
They're genuine temptations,
and in a lot of ways,
he's imported the notion of
these temptations from his
favorite canto of The Faerie
Queene,
the cave of Mammon canto
from Book Two.So Milton
takes his cue from Spenser and
transforms this second
temptation into a catalog of all
of those activities,
all of those seemingly virtuous
activities, that he had himself
devoted his life to.
This massive and seemingly
endlessly elaborated second
temptation reads something like
Milton's autobiography.
He explores,
with what I take to be an
almost painful precision,
the central drives and the
impulses of his very being.
Satan tempts the Son of God
with wealth.
He tempts the Son of God with
revolutionary political
commitment with the promise of
military success.
He offers Jesus the entire
Parthian army to help him regain
the throne of David,
because of course everybody
knows Jesus will eventually
regain the throne of David.
He tempts the Son with empire.
He offers to give him the
empire of Rome since the current
emperor, Tiberius,
is so old and corrupt anyway,
and he tempts him finally with
all of the beauty and all of the
wisdom and all of the fame
associated with classical
Athens.
In short, Satan tempts the Son
with just about everything that
was ever important to our John
Milton.
It's almost as if Milton had
deliberately structured the
second temptation as something
like a review session for the
Milton exam.
You have an entire career
narrated here.So in the
temptation to wealth -- and I've
given you a sense of the dates
but it's also on your handout --
in the temptation to wealth you
have the protestations of action
and of merit,
that guilty defensiveness that
you saw in the lyrics of the
1630s and in that Latin poem,
"Ad Patrem," that Milton had
written to his father.
In the temptation to political
commitment or the temptation to
intervene politically,
you have Milton's new
commitment, the commitment of in
the 1640s -- the decade of his
prose -- to apply his literary
energies to the goal of the
Puritan Revolution,
the desire to reform the
corruption of church and state.
In the temptation to Parthian
military glory,
you can hear Milton's
conviction in the regicide
treatises of 1649 and
thereabouts,
his conviction in the
importance of destroying with
force, by actual military power,
the unlawful tyranny of Charles
the First.
In the temptation of the Roman
empire, you have reflected the
faith that Milton seemed to hold
in the early 1650s,
at least, in the almost
unlimited, utopian potential of
the Puritan commonwealth:
the hope -- and it turned out
to be a crazy and perfectly
irrational hope -that an empire
governed by the virtuous Puritan
saints might actually be able to
precipitate the millennium,
or the apocalypse,
at the end of time.
In the last part of Satan's
second temptation,
you have Satan's absolutely
delicious and completely
irresistible offer of literary
fame and classical wisdom in the
form of classical Athens.
Clearly, this last addition to
the second temptation -- that is
the thing that persists
throughout Milton's career.
It obviously spans his entire
life.So Milton alludes to
and recycles in the elaborated
second temptation all of the
virtuous commitments and all of
the disciplined decisions that
he had been making himself over
the course of the last forty
years.
He presents them -- and this is
what's so brilliant -- he
presents them in a form that the
hero has to resist.
They're temptations that the
The voices in his head that had
come to him through the
mechanism of conscience -- or
God or John Milton,
Sr.
or someone authoritative -- all
of those authoritative voices
are now crystalized in the
person and the shape of Satan.
Satan is tempting the Son of
God with a version of
essentially all of the virtuous
behavior that Milton's father
had pressured Milton
with.Now,
it's usually clear that the
Satanic version -- and this is
almost always clear -- that the
Satanic version of the
temptation is an evil,
or at least a questionable,
rendition of the virtuous
action that Milton himself had
over the course of those years
felt obliged to perform,
but it's not always perfectly
clear to me as a reader why it
is that all of Satan's arguments
are faulty,
or why it is we have to dismiss
them necessarily as evil.
It often seems that the Son of
God is rejecting modes of action
and types of virtuous commitment
that Milton himself actively
embraced -- which is just a way
of saying there's nothing that
Milton is not willing to
question in this poem.
He's struggling to reinterpret,
in some way,
his entire career,
as if to purify it of anything
like a self-interested motive.
It's as if he's systematically
reviewing and scrutinizing every
move, every type of action that
he had been engaged in over the
years,
in order to purify his own past
by differentiating it in some
way from its Satanic double,
from a dark version of his own
virtue.Okay.
Let's turn to page 510 in the
Hughes.
This is Book Three,
line 224.
This is a good example of the
way in which Milton will cast as
a Satanic temptation the voice
of virtuous conscience that had
plagued him as a younger man.
So Satan asks,
"If you have such hopes to be
the savior of your nation -- and
of course you do -- why don't
you hurry up and act?
Come on.
Do something."
Look at line 224:
Why move thy feet so slow
to what is best?
[Now I'll skip a couple of
lines here.]
…..
Perhaps thou linger'st in deep
thoughts detain'd
Of the enterprise so hazardous
and high;
No wonder;
for though in thee be united
What of perfection can in man
be found,
Or human nature can receive,
consider
Thy life hath yet been private
[This is quite a jab:
You're not really fit for
public action at all],
most part spent
At home, scarce view'd the
Galilean Towns,
And once a year
Jerusalem…
Satan's saying,
"Oh, I know why you're hesitant
to act.
You're too busy lingering in
all of your deep thoughts.
You've spent all of your life
at home and you've never
ventured out.
You've never sallied forth to
do something in the world."
Milton has incorporated into
Satan's temptation a piercing
critique of his own tendency,
that early tendency,
to wait -- to anticipate rather
than to act.
Satan tempts the Son with the
wisdom of John Milton,
Sr.: "You've spent most of your
life in private at home,
reading.
Why in God's name don't you
do something?"Now,
let's jump ahead to the final
moment of the second temptation,
which is another of Milton's
additions to the story that has
absolutely no basis in scripture
whatsoever.
Of course, its absence from
Milton's biblical source should
only draw our attention all the
more to its importance.
This is the temptation to the
intellectual fame represented by
classical Athens in Book Four.
Turn to Book Four, line 240.
Satan displays before the Son
all of the cultural wealth of
ancient Athens,
and at line 240 he invokes
Athens,
"the eye of Greece,
Mother of Arts / and
Eloquence."
This Athens,
the "Mother of Arts," seems to
possess within it all of the
classical learning that Milton
himself had been addicted to as
a young man as he spent those
years after college in studious
retirement at his family's
house.Look down at line 281.
Satan urges the Son to read all
of these great classical texts.
This is just getting so close
to home.
Satan says to the Son:
"These here revolve,
or, as thou lik'st,
at home."
This is amazing.
It's as if Satan were imagining
something like a lending
library, and nothing could be
more tempting to Milton.
The Son could actually think
about, read, and ponder these
works in the privacy of his own
home.
This line here [laughs]
convinces me that Milton
himself had an enormous book
collection.
The books were his -- he read
them at home after he was in
college.
He wasn't merely reading them
in a nobleman's house or a
friend's copy or in some version
of a library.
Milton must have read at home,
until:
These here revolve,
or, as thou lik'st,
at home,
Till time mature thee to a
Kingdom's weight;
These rules will render thee a
King complete
Within thyself,
much more with Empire
join'd.
This temptation to immerse
himself in pagan literature at
home, of course,
is the temptation in
Paradise Regained that
has to be most difficult for
Milton to imagine resisting.
Of course, I think it's the
most difficult temptation for us
as readers to encounter.
It's impossible,
in fact, to read the Son's
response to Satan's temptation
here without wincing,
without wincing at the pain
that had to have accompanied
Milton's writing of it.
This is the Son who becomes
unbelievably puritanical at this
point in a stereotypical sense
-- this is the top of page 523,
line 322 of Book Four.
The Son says to Satan:
[W]ho reads
Incessantly,
and to his reading brings not
A spirit and judgment equal or
superior
(And what he brings,
what needs he elsewhere seek)
Uncertain and unsettl'd still
remains,
Deep verst in books and shallow
in himself,
Crude or intoxicate,
collecting toys,
And trifles for choice matters,
worth a sponge [a sponge is an
eraser];
As Children gathering pebbles
on the shore.
The Son dismisses literature --
he dismisses all of secular
learning as mere toys fit for
children.
You can hear something like the
voice of Milton's father here
accusing Milton of childishness.
You can also see hear the
important association of
literature with the domestic
sphere,
the space of the home -- the
sphere of experience that's
governed not by the child's
father but by the child's
mother.
It's important,
I think, that Athens is very
carefully figured by Milton as
the mother of arts,
because this kind of learning
is presented and represented in
Milton's poem as a maternal
inheritance.
It's just this maternal
inheritance that the Son has to
resist -- because what's his
purpose here in this poem?
It's perfect sole obedience to
the Father.
The Son's rejection of
classical learning really
parallels Milton's own as he
writes this very poem.
On some level he's describing
for us what he himself is doing.
He's obviously resisting
classical literature,
or at least allusion to
throughout Paradise
Regained.
This poem is almost -- and
of course, I can only say
"almost" -- it's almost scoured
of any classical references
whatsoever.Well,
the exquisitely abstemious Son
of God resists this most
tempting of temptations just as
he has resisted all the others.
This is the big gun that Satan
has just pulled out,
and Satan understandably is
beside himself with frustration.
Look at line 366,
top of page 524:
Satan is "quite at a loss,
for all his darts were
spent..."
Satan has nothing else to ask
but this astonishing question at
line 372.
Look at Satan's question at
line 372: "What dost thou in
this World?"
In other words,
"You have rejected every form
of action, and I can't imagine
that you're actually willing to
do anything.
This is ridiculous.
Can you do anything but say no?"
Satan asks the Son.What,
of course, Satan doesn't
understand yet is that this poem
isn't about action.
It's not about doing,
but on some important level
it's about knowledge.
Particularly,
it's about self-knowledge and
it's the problem of knowledge
that really comes to the fore at
the third and final temptation,
which goes like this:
"If you are,
as you claim,
the real Son of God,
then prove it,"
Satan challenges the Son.
So the third temptation is
essentially a paternity test.
It's a test in his faith in who
his father is.
Satan's coming to the point
where he has to learn once and
for all exactly who this Son is,
and it's here that Satan takes
the Son to the top of the
pinnacle -- the Father's house,
the top of the temple -- to
prove that he is,
in fact, a Son of God.
Satan is going back,
he's returning once again to
that proclamation that the
Father had made at the baptism,
"This is my beloved Son."
He has to figure out once and
for all what that meant.So
look at page 527.
This is Book Four,
line 515, Satan to the Son:
[I want to] learn
In what degree or meaning thou
art call'd
The Son of God,
which bears no single sense;
The Son of God I also am,
or was,
And, if I was, I am;
relation stands…
The relation of past and
present, the relation of who I
was to who I am,
is finally presented here
explicitly.
This is the big question,
and it's here that the extent
of what we can think of Satan's
repression becomes almost
unbearable for me to witness.
Satan insists that the Son of
God is a term that can be used
indiscriminately to describe all
of God's human and angelic
creatures, and he's right.
It was used pretty much
indiscriminately throughout a
lot of Paradise Lost.
Satan is incapable here of
acknowledging to himself the
identity of this Son of God,
this opponent,
with that Son of God -- the Son
of God, the so-called only
begotten,
the first begotten,
in heaven way back when:
that Son of God whose favor in
the eyes of the Father had,
of course, motivated Satan's
fall from heaven in the first
place and had motivated the
rebellion.Satan brings the
Son to the top of the temple and
he asks the Son to cast himself
down.
It's incredible the degree to
which this climactic moment in
this poem reworks that climactic
moment in the other poem -- from
the war in heaven in Paradise
Lost.
It's as if unconsciously,
Satan is trying to re-stage
that fall from heaven perhaps,
in some sort of fantasy way,
to have it have a different
outcome -- that terrible moment
at which the Son had
successfully maneuvered Satan
and the other rebel angels into
casting themselves down from
heaven.
It's as if this were a
desperate attempt to redo a
traumatic moment in the familial
past.
Satan tempts the Son to call
upon the Father to lift him up,
since it is written in
scripture that angels will rush
to the aid of the Son of God.
In essence, if you are in fact
the Son of God,
prove it!
Call upon the Father to help
you.It's at this point in
Milton's text that absolutely
everything that we've been
discussing comes to a head.
It's a remarkable convergence.
Look at line 560 on page 528:
"To whom thus Jesus.
Also it is written,
/ Tempt not the Lord thy God;
he said, and stood.
/ But Satan,
smitten with amazement
fell…"
The Son of God performs no
action here other than quoting a
verse, a verse from the Book of
Deuteronomy,
and then stands,
or maybe actually just remains
standing.
He refuses to honor Satan's
request, and he exhibits his
complete and total obedience to
the Father by quoting the
Father's word,
by quoting scripture:
"Tempt not the Lord thy
God."It's at this point,
and it is not before this
point,
that the truth of the Son's
identity becomes evident to
Satan, I think.
I think this is also the moment
at which the truth of the Son's
identity becomes apparent also
to the Son.
On one level Jesus merely
means, don't tempt the Lord thy
God;
don't tempt the Lord to help
you if you don't really need his
help, if you can do it on your
own.
But at the very moment that the
Son quotes the Father's
scripture, it's almost as if the
meaning of this scriptural verse
changes before our very eyes.
"Tempt not the Lord thy God"
comes also to mean -- maybe by
the time he's gotten to the God
part -- it comes also to mean,
perhaps, "Don't tempt me
because I am in some way the
Lord thy God."
At this very moment of absolute
obedience, the Son is rewarded
with the knowledge that he is
not only the Savior or the
Messiah -- he's known that
–
but he's rewarded with the
knowledge that in some sense he
is God himself.It's an
incredible moment,
and it's at this moment that
it's as if this poem's
repression of Paradise Lost,
the earlier poem,
has been lifted.
The repression that has
obscured the identity of this
Son of God with that Son of God,
the Son of God who was actually
responsible for driving out
Satan from heaven in the first
place -- the repression
evaporates.
As soon as the reality of the
situation asserts itself once
again, it's amazing:
Satan falls headlong to his
destruction.
It's as if all of these pieces
of the puzzle are suddenly
fitting together,
and finally the identity of
this Son of God with that Son of
God in Paradise Lost is
established.
It seems to me that everybody
in the poem is surprised,
even the heavenly
angels.Look at line 605 of
Book Four.
This is where the angels are
singing in praise of the Son.
I'm convinced that it's only
now that they realize who this
guy is, which means who this guy
had been.
So the angels tell the Son in
this heavenly hymn,
and they're speaking of Satan
here:
[H]im long of old
Thou didst debel [debel means
to conquer in war],
and down from Heav'n cast
With all his Army;
now thou hast aveng'd
Supplanted Adam,
and by vanquishing
Temptation, hast regain'd lost
Paradise…
This is the first moment that
this poem has acknowledged the
Son's agency in the war that was
represented in the earlier poem.
Finally, the connection between
Paradise Lost and
Paradise Regained is
established.Look at that
last line that I just read,
line 608.
You have something like the
visual indication of the
conjunction of the two poems.
Their titles are compressed
into three words.
Both titles are compressed into
three words: "regain'd lost
Paradise."
I think it's one of the
greatest, most exciting
revelation scenes in all of
Western literature.
The entire phenomenon of
recovered memory -- the
recovered memory,
for example,
of years later of past
traumatic abuse -- is obviously
one that only really began to
assert itself later in the
twentieth century,
or in the early '90s with Oprah
and Roseanne,
although you probably don't
remember Roseanne's recovered
memory.
But Milton was representing
just this phenomenon,
the phenomenon of recovered
memory, in 1671,
and he represented it on an
unbelievably huge scale.
It's not just the revelation of
a character's identity.
It's the identity of an entire
text.
What is that text?
The text is only the greatest
poem ever written in English
that is brought to light at this
moment.
The Son by resisting the
Satan's temptation has regained
lost paradise but Milton has
regained Paradise Lost
and allowed us to regain
Paradise
Lost.Remember at the
beginning that it seemed that
Milton had actually forgotten
the epic content of his poem:
"Oh,
I was just writing some
pastoral and I called it
Paradise Lost, but
now -- eureka!
" It's like an enormous bolt of
lightning hits him and he
remembers.
He remembers that Paradise
Lost was,
in fact, an epic and according
to Milton it's this revelation
which is the moment at which man
is redeemed.
This is the moment at which
paradise is regained,
and the Son proves his identity
through the simple quotation of
scripture -- nothing
imaginative,
nothing fancy.
He's quoting the Bible:
"Tempt not the Lord thy God."
Milton proves his own obedience
to God by his composition of a
biblical epic that is virtually
untainted by the ornaments of
classical literature.So it
is at this moment [laughs]
of proof that everything in
Paradise Regained is
permitted to change.
As soon as Milton describes
Satan's fall,
he allows himself to embrace --
and we're so happy for this --
to embrace a poetic mode that
had been completely suppressed
up to this point,
and this is the sublime mode of
epic grandeur.
All of a sudden we have not one
epic simile, but we have two,
and it's as if we're breathing
oxygen again.
Milton compares the Son's
victory over Satan to Hercules'
defeat of Antaeus,
Antaeus being the figure who
gained his strength from his
mother, the earth,
every time he touched the
ground.
Milton, of course,
is also figuring the victory of
Christianity over the maternal
arts of Greece.Finally,
at line 572,
Milton compares Satan to the
Theban sphinx.
Look at line 572:
And as that Theban
monster that propos'dHer
riddle, and him who solv'd it
not,
devour'd,That once found
out and solv'd,
for grief and spiteCast
herself headlong from th'
Ismenian steep…
Now, Milton doesn't mention
here who it was who found out
and solved the riddle of the
sphinx.
He doesn't mention who it was
who impelled the sphinx to cast
herself headlong from the
Ismenian steep.
Like Satan who has repressed up
to this point the name of who it
was who had caused him to hurl
himself from heaven,
Milton -- in a kind of
interesting and really related
way -- Milton is repressing the
name of that classical hero
here;
but of course we know.
We know who solved the riddle
of the sphinx and we know that
the Son of God is implicitly
being compared to him:
it was Oedipus.
It was Oedipus who was able to
answer the riddle posed by the
sphinx, and it was Oedipus whose
answer pressed the sphinx to
cast herself off that high
precipice.What was the
sphinx's riddle?
Some of you will remember.
The riddle was,
what creature goes first on
four legs, then on two legs,
and then finally on three legs?
And Oedipus' ingenious answer
was "man": because man is born
to crawl on all fours,
initially, then grows up to
walk on two legs,
and ends his life as an old man
with a cane,
or what amounts to three legs.
Before this simile,
Satan had asked the Son a
riddle, essentially,
and the riddle was:
who are you?
The Son's answer to that riddle
was -- it was kind of,
"I am the Lord thy God."
Oedipus' answer to the riddle
of the sphinx was "man," and
it's been one conjecture,
and I think it's a very strong
one, that the truth of the Son's
identity in Paradise Regained
involves,
in some way,
a combination of those two
answers.
The Son of God is both God and
man, and you could see Milton
using these classical illusions
in some way to encode the
mysterious truth of the Son's
identity and to encode the
mystery of the
incarnation.Now there is,
of course, much more to the
story of Oedipus than Milton is
alluding to in this simile.
Oedipus is most famous for
having killed his father and
then having married his mother.
Since Paradise Regained
is a poem that is everywhere
concerned with repression,
with all of those things that
it refuses to acknowledge,
it's surely not too far-fetched
to imagine the relation of
Milton's poem to that most
obvious aspect of the classical
story of Oedipus.
This is, after all,
the classical myth that became
for Freud the dominant myth of
repression.
Milton, by the way -- this is a
conjecture from a brilliant
Freudian reading of Milton by a
critic named William Kerrigan --
Milton was one of Freud's
favorite poets,
and it's been argued that
Milton in a lot of ways in
Paradise Lost and
Paradise Regained
provides Freud with some of
the intellectual tools by which
he developed the complicated
notion of the Oedipus
complex.In any case,
I think you have in Paradise
Regained as powerful a
representation of repression as
anything that you could find in
the pages of Freud.
So in Sophocles' famous
tragedy, Oedipus Rex,
Oedipus kills his father
and moves in with his mother,
Jocasta, the Queen of Thebes.
I don't want to suggest -- this
is what I'm willing to repress
here -- that Milton's interested
in the sexual element of the
Son's relation to his mother,
although of course we know that
Milton does have an interest in
incest: think of Satan,
Sin, and Death in Paradise
Lost.
But Milton's very much
interested, I think,
in the fact that Oedipus killed
his father.
There's a very real sense in
which the Son's defeat of Satan
in Paradise Regained is a
literary rewriting of the
hostility,
the simmering resentment,
of John Milton,
Jr.
to John Milton, Sr.
Above all things,
the Son resents the temptation
to act in a way that the public
world values as important.
Milton's laying to rest once
and for all -- his father is
already dead -- but once and for
all the censorious,
judgmental voice of his
father.We might even be able
to say that he has hereby in
some figurative way killed his
earthly father.
His patricide is closely
related to what is happening at
the actual narrative of the poem
when the Son of God realizes at
that extraordinary moment that
he himself is God.
The Son of God identifies with
God, with the Father,
and by means of that
identification in some way
displaces or renders unnecessary
-- we could say even kills --
the father.
When the Son internalizes the
authority of the Father and
actually becomes on some level
the Father himself,
it's as if the Father as a
meaningful, external reality
were dead.Well,
critics have always been
puzzled and astounded by this
ending of Paradise
Regained.
After the moment of the Son's
victory over Satan on the
pinnacle, the entire poem seems
to shift gears.
All of a sudden,
this is the Milton we recognize
and love.
All of a sudden the quality of
the verse begins to revert back
to that rich,
densely textured style of
Paradise Lost.
The Son himself,
on the level of plot,
is rewarded for his victory
with the beautiful assistance of
angels who come to feed him and
Milton, too.
On the poetic level,
as a poet, Milton is rewarded.
He's successfully resisted the
poetic lushness of Paradise
Lost up to this point,
and he's permitted for his
pains to return to that lush and
extravagant style.
He's acutely aware of the new
direction, I think,
that the poem is taking at this
point.Look at the last line
of the poem: "hee unobserv'd /
Home to his Mother's house
private return'd."
The Son is rewarded for his
efforts in good,
Oedipal fashion with the
mother.
The Son has proven himself
victorious in the Father's
house, the temple,
and it's only after that
victory that he can reassume the
pleasures of the domestic
sphere,
the space of the mother.
I think that Milton's ending is
also Milton's best description
of what it is that actually
happens in the remarkable
conclusion to this remarkable
poem.
He has renounced so much in his
composition of Paradise
Regained.
He has forsaken his love of
wandering verse.
He's forsaken all of that
learned allusiveness for a
highly disciplined,
austere,
and severely repressive style
and, just as the Son in the poem
is rewarded for his obedience to
the Father with the return to
his mother's house,
Milton is rewarded for his own
literary submission to the
austere style of the Father's
gospel.It's almost as if,
retrospectively,
Milton can now be said to have
earned the right to have written
Paradise Lost.
He can identify himself now
as someone who was entitled to
have written Paradise Lost.
Milton was rewarded at the
end of the poem with the
triumphant return to the
imagery,
the wisdom, and the beauty of
his beloved classics,
and he justifies to himself and
to his reader how it is he can
be a dutiful Christian poet who
can also at the same time
indulge at will in the great
pagan classics.
He's proven himself to the
heavenly father and he can now
-- it's as if he can read and
write as freely as anything that
he was able to imagine way back
in 1644 in Areopagitica.
The ending,
the last line of this poem,
is so incredibly beautiful --
this quiet,
exquisite ending -- and when we
read that the Son of God returns
home to his mother's house,
we have an image,
I think, of a similar return on
the part of the poet.
Milton is returning -- almost
but not entirely unobserved --
to the paradise of Greece,
mother of arts and
eloquence.Okay.
We are in for the home stretch.
We have four more things to do.
Friday we will all be meeting
in LC 102 -- is that right?
Yes, in LC 102.
Instead of sections,
we will be meeting as a group
-- this is the size of the
section actually -- as a group
in LC 102.
You have to begin to prepare
yourselves for the final poem,
Samson Agonistes.
Make sure that you all have
read it all.
It's not very long,
but it's pretty friggin'
intense.
Read it all by Monday's class.
Okay.